[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg
Samstagabend schön dass Sie dabei sind
wie auch Rudi Cerne für den Sport hallo
schönen guten Abend und das sind die
Nachrichten Themen des Tages
billigerer Strom für die Industrie
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck plant einen
gedeckelten Strompreis für Unternehmen
mit hohem Verbrauch
Brandbrief europäischer Mediziner
Kinderärzte warnen vor weiteren
medikamenten-
und Drohnenangriff auf Sebastopol auf
der von Russland annektierten Krim geht
ein Treibstofflager in Flammen auf
[Musik]
seit langem klagt die deutsche Industrie
die hohen Strompreise sein ein
Wettbewerbsnachteil um zu verhindern das
wichtige Technologien ins Ausland
abwandern werben SPD und Grüne dafür den
industriestrompreis mit staatlicher
Hilfe noch weiter zu decken
schon jetzt bekommen Großkunden etwa
Chemie oder Metallunternehmen ihren
Strom deutlich günstiger als
Privathaushalte und stehen im
europäischen Vergleich trotzdem eher
schlechter eine Kilowattstunde Strom
kostet die Industrie hierzulande rund 20
Cent nur in wenigen großen EU-Ländern
Italien etwa zahlt sie mehr in
Frankreich zum Beispiel deutlich weniger
Diana Zimmermann über die Pläne des
Wirtschaftsministers
Aluminium gießen und Energiesparen das
passt nicht gut zusammen für diese und
andere Industrien ist der Strompreis ein
entscheidender Kostenfaktor und der ist
in Deutschland hoch Gewerkschaften und
Industrie schlagen Alarm warnen vor dem
Verlust hunderttausender Jobs der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister will nun den
Strompreis für die Industrie Deckeln
der Zugang zu erneuerbaren Energien ist
der industriestrompreis der Zukunft die
müssen aber in den großen Mengen
ausgebaut werden bis dahin bin ich der
Meinung dass man für die sich im
internationalen Wettbewerb befindliche
Industrie die sonst abwandern wird und
die hoch Energie intensiv ist eine
weitere Hilfeleistung geben muss die
Idee kommt ursprünglich vom Kanzler
damals als er noch Kandidat war
versprach Olaf Scholz der Industrie
diese Hilfe Kritik die Maßnahme lade zu
Energieverschwendung ein weiß die SPD
zurück jedes Unternehmen weiß inzwischen
was Preis diese Energie bedeuten
insofern gehe ich davon aus dass das
Thema Effizienz immer eine Rolle spielen
wird und wir können im übrigen auch den
industriestrompreis intelligent mit
Effizienzmaßnahmen verkoppeln selbst der
CDU-Vorsitzende zieht mit die
Bundesregierung hat eine Zusage gegeben
einen industriestrompreis in Deutschland
zu etablieren die Bundesregierung muss
dieses Versprechen einlösen irgendwo
unter 10 Cent pro Kilowattstunde solle
der Preis landen mindestens sechs
Milliarden Euro wird diese Pension
Kosten der Finanzminister ist nicht
begeistert auch das Institut der
deutschen Wirtschaft warnt statt des
industriestrompreises brauche ist
Förderung von Forschungen Entwicklung
Förderung von Investitionen bessere
Rahmenbedingungen schnellere
Genehmigungsverfahren aber nicht
Subvention für Energie per se das ist
ein Irrweg der teuer ist der
konterproduktiv ist und letztlich den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland nicht
sichern wird
Kritik ist auch aus Brüssel zu erwarten
wie schon bei der Gas und Strompreis
Bremse wird kritisiert das Reich in
Deutschland verzerren mit seinen
Subventionen den Wettbewerb innerhalb
der EU
der Wirtschaftsminister hat sie eben
gesagt wichtig für den Strompreis ist
der Ausbau der erneuerbaren Energien
Windkraft z.B da hat jedes Bundesland je
nach Platz und Wind seine Ziele und
tatsächlich geht es in Deutschland auch
voran allerdings im Norden erheblich
besser als im Süden Bremser sind
Bürokratie und Klagen Svenja Domeyer hat
Details
seit fünf Jahren warten im Landkreis
Göttingen zwei Windräder auf ihre
Fertigstellung eine Klage von
Naturschutzbund hatte den Bau gestoppt
im zweiten Anlauf schaut die zuständige
Behörde nun noch genauer hin unsere
Aufgabe als Genehmigungsbehörde ist es
nun mal auch Artenschutz und Klimaschutz
in Einklang zu bringen und das ganze
gerichtsfest denn Klagen sind keine
Seltenheit gegen ein Drittel der
ausgewiesenen Flächen wird in
Deutschland prozessiert der Landkreis
Rotenburg soll seine windkraftflächen
verfünffachen schwierig auch weil
Gesetze für eine Beschleunigung der
Verfahren in vielen Ländern noch in
Arbeit sind man kann nicht duschen ohne
nass zu werden wenn sie einerseits sagen
sie wollen großflächig ich finde Energie
ausbauen und gleichzeitig jeden
wutvogelplatz schützen wollen in
Deutschland dann wird das nicht mehr
miteinander kompatibel sein
und dennoch tut sich etwas im ersten
Quartal dieses Jahres ging bundesweit
128 neue Anlagen an den Staat 28% mehr
als im Vorjahreszeitraum noch deutlicher
die Steigerung bei den Genehmigungen 317
Anlagen bekam grünes Licht ein Plus von
49% doch der Erfolg konzentriert sich im
Norden Schleswig-Holstein Niedersachsen
NRW auch Brandenburg aber der Süden
insbesondere Bayern Baden-Württemberg
Sachsen ein Totalausfall Genehmigungen
für gerade zwei Windräder in Bayern und
eins in Baden-Württemberg in diesem Jahr
will der Süden für die Industrie
attraktiv bleiben muss er beim Ausbau
schleunigst nachziehen
das Kabinett hat das Verbot fossiler
Heizungen vor zwei Wochen verabschiedet
doch SPD-Chef Klingbeil sieht noch
Änderungsbedarf man werde prüfen ob es
bei der sozialen abfederungen noch
Nachbesserungen brauche so klingen weil
in der Frankfurter Allgemeinen
Sonntagszeitung beim Thema Heizen hätten
viele Bürger so wörtlich Angst dass sie
richtig hart auf den Boden knallen das
dürfen nicht passieren
Ärzte schlagen Alarm europaweit sei die
Gesundheit unserer kindergefährdet
schreiben Sie in einem Brandbrief es
Ruhe ein gravierender Mangel an
Medikamenten grundsätzlich sind
Medikamente seit Jahren immer schwerer
zu bekommen 2018 waren 265 knapp im
vergangenen Jahr schon 564 und gerade
verschärft sich der Trend noch deutlich
weiter weil organisatorisch und
politisch einiges schief lief im Herbst
könnte es für die Kinder noch heftiger
werden Simon Rubisch und Fabian Köhler
berichten
das Lager der hirsch-Apotheke im
niedersächsischen Schellerten
Apothekerin Stefanie Strube kann viele
Regalböden nicht mehr auffüllen so wie
ihr geht es aktuell vielen Kollegen sind
leider nicht nur die Antibiotika
betroffen sondern auch diverse andere
Medikamente Herzmedikamente
Blutdrucksenker sind dabei auch unsere
wichtigen Insuline rund 500
rezeptpflichtige Medikamente fehlen oder
sind nur schwer zu bekommen eine
schnelle Besserung nicht in Sicht
Kinderärzte schlagen auf europäischer
Ebene Alarm in einem offenen Brief
fordern sie die Politik auf etwas zu
unternehmen es trifft uns jeden Tag bei
jedem einzelnen Antibiotikum was wir
verschreiben so dass es tatsächlich ein
alltägliches Problem ist was für die
Kinder und Jugendlichen so ähm ja unter
Umständen schweren gesundheitlichen
Folgen führen kann wenn eben keiner
Medikamente mehr verordnet werden können
immer häufiger müssen Apotheker die
Arztpraxen kontaktieren es geht um
alternative Präparate oder eine
Abänderung des Rezeptes
für die Ärztinnen und Ärzte ist das ein
Ungeheuer Mehraufwand weil die Praxen
sowieso voll sind aufgrund der
infektwelle im Moment und wenn sie dann
noch Rückruf vor den apothekeren
Apothekern bekommen ob sie austauschen
dürfen dann sind diese Rückrufe allein
eine hohe zeitliche Zusatzbelastung
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach nennt die
Sorge der Kinderärzte berechtigt den
Medikamenten Mangel will er mit dem
sogenannten lieferengpass-gesetz
bekämpfen und Anreize für
Pharmahersteller schaffen wir brauchen
einen Teil der Produktion hier in Europa
also wir können uns nicht darauf
verlassen langfristig dass wir die
wichtige Antibiotika ich sage mal aus
Ländern wie China oder Indien
zuverlässig bekommen bis die Industrie
ihre Produktion nach Deutschland oder
Europa verlegt ist die nächste
Grippewelle aber wohl längst da so die
Befürchtung der Fachleute die Suche nach
ersatzpräparaten wird weiter Alltag in
Apotheken bleiben
zum Krieg in der Ukraine nach einem
Drohnenangriff steht auf der von
Russland völkerrechtswidrig annektierten
Krim ein Treibstofflager in Flammen
bekennt sich nicht offiziell zu dem
Angriff der Militärgeheimdienst spricht
aber von einer Strafe Gottes für
ermordete Zivilisten in Oman dort waren
bei einem russischen Angriff gestern 23
Menschen getötet worden aus der Ukraine
ein Großbrand den Sevastopol mächtige
Flammen genährt von Treibstofftanks laut
russischen Angaben haben ukrainische
Drohnen den Großbrand verursacht in der
Hafenstadt auf der annektierten Krim hat
die russische Schwarzmeerflotte ihren
Sitz Angriffe auf Logistik und
Versorgung der russischen Armee im
Vorfeld der angekündigten Großoffensive
für diese Offensive laufen die
Vorbereitung ein Trainingscamp für
kampferprobte Einheiten unweit der Front
sie üben Angriffe im Verbund
ziel dieses Trainings ist es die Truppen
so auszubilden dass sie feindliche
Linien durchbrechen können es sind
angriffsübungen im Kampf bewährt hat
sich dieser mehrfach Raketenwerfer
sowjetischer Bauart in Kombination mit
modernen Geländewagen
ich kann sagen dass der Feind selbst 20
km hinter der Frontlinie nicht mehr
sicher ist sie sind schnell und flexibel
wir können Sie jeden Moment treffen und
Sie wissen nicht wo und wann
vom Training an die umkämpfte Front bei
wolle da im Don Bass dort konnte die
ukrainische Armee heute die russischen
Truppen drei Kilometer zurückdrängen
auch weil ihr Material jetzt besser ist
es ist Musik in unseren Ohren wenn wir
diese neuen Klänge hören es bedeutet
unsere Jungs haben neue Waffen unsere
Artillerie wird besser und besser
es sind einzelne militärische
Operationen der letzten 24 Stunden ob
sie bereits Teil der angekündigten
Großoffensive sind wird die Zeit zeigen
der Streit zwischen der EU und mehreren
osteuropäischen Mitgliedsstaaten über
agrarimporte aus der Ukraine ist
beigelegt fünf umliegende Länder
darunter Polen dürfen einige Erzeugnisse
von ihren Märkten fernhalten sie
erlauben im Gegenzug aber den Transit
aller Agrarprodukte Landwirte in den
Ländern hatten sich über einen
preisverfall-
Papst franziskus ist derzeit zu Besuch
in Ungarn in einem Land dessen
Flüchtlingspolitik zwei Gesichter hat
ukrainische geflüchtete sind willkommen
andere weniger vor allem Migranten aus
Afrika und Asien lehnt die Regierung
Orban ab franziskus kritisierte das mit
klaren Worten und forderte Ungarn auf
jedem in Not zu helfen zustimmend
äußerte sich der Pontifex aber zur
ebenfalls umstrittenen ungarischen
Familienpolitik wolf-
dass der Papst heute Vormittag einen
Gottesdienst mit armen Menschen und mit
Flüchtlingen in Budapest feiert ist eine
Botschaft
die Armen und die Bedürftigen stehen im
Mittelpunkt des Evangeliums
für Ungarns Ministerpräsidenten Viktor
Orban bringt der Papstbesuch
Unterstützung und Mahnung der Papst
unterstützt Orbans konservative
Familienpolitik und den Feldzug gegen
queere Menschen er spricht vom
unheilvollen Weg der genderkultur und
vom Recht auf Abtreibung als tragische
Niederlage
andererseits deutliche Kritik an Orbans
restriktiver Flüchtlingspolitik
franziskus zitiert dafür und ganz
Nationalheiligen König Stefan dieser
Kommando Diak deshalb empfehle ich dir
fremde wohlwollend aufzunehmen und sie
in Ehren zu halten damit sie lieber bei
dir bleiben als anderen Ort
hier wird man diese Botschaft mit
Genugtuung aufgenommen haben Pfarrer
Gabor ivani bietet in seiner Karten
hilfsstation Obdachlosen und
Flüchtlingen Brot und Schlafplatz die
Regierung Orban rühme sich zwar
christlich zu sein sagt er doch tue sie
viel zu wenig und den schwächsten zu
helfen
an Ostern hat der Papst den Flüchtlingen
die Füße gewaschen und auch geküsst wenn
noch Viktor Orban die Füße von
Flüchtlingen waschen und küssen würde
wäre das eine wichtige Nachricht für
mich die Realität aber ist dass er allem
hassfreien Lauf lässt
wie zum Beweis nahm Ungarns Präsidentin
Nowak ausgerechnet den Papst Besuch zum
Anlass einen gewalttätigen rechts
Terroristen aus dem Gefängnis zu lassen
Orban nutzt also den Besuch in
Wirtschaft die schwierigen Zeiten für
schöne Bilder fraglich jedoch ob er die
Botschaft der Nächstenliebe so verstehen
will wie der Papst sie meint
jetzt zu einem Geburtstagskind das unser
Leben komplett verändert hat vor 30
Jahren wurde das World Wide Web
freigegeben jüngeren muss man das
erklären statt Google gab es Lexika zum
Nachschlagen shoppen gegen nur in der
Stadt im Geschäft und niemand wäre auf
die Idee gekommen im Computer nach
Gefährten zu suchen Sven Ricken über
eine technische Revolution im
Computermuseum der Hamburger Universität
steht ein halbes Jahrhundert
Computergeschichte die Dinosaurier der
Datenverarbeitung gehören längst zum
alten it-eisen trotzdem können einige
Rechner hier noch heute ins World Wide
Web es waren nämlich genau diese sehr
unterschiedlichen Computertypen die der
englische Informatiker Tim burnies Lee
in einem Netz zusammenbringen wollte
man konnte zwar E-Mails versenden aber
man konnte nicht schnell Informationen
abrufen und so wie wir das Netz heute
kennen ist es eigentlich vor allem
dadurch entstanden dass die Nutzerinnen
und Nutzer ihre Inhalte noch mitgebracht
haben vier Jahre tüftelte Lee am zern
Forschungszentrum in Genf dann konnte er
endlich auf alle Inhalte aller Rechner
auf dem Campus zugreifen und musste
nicht mehr bei Wind und Wetter vor die
Tür erst dadurch machte er den ersten
Browser und die heutige Online-Welt
möglich mit all ihren Vorzügen und
Gefahren
weniger Fake News das ist einfach die
Inhalte nach wie vor gut sind mehr
Sicherheit auf jeden Fall ja äh für
Kinder sowieso inzwischen sind
Webanwendungen längst Alltag und
Sprachgebrauch die Tools laufen auf
zentralen Servern Nutzer greifen von
außen zu ohne selbst etwas auf dem
Rechner installieren zu müssen wohin das
noch führt der nächste Schritt wird sein
dass eben auch durchaus
vielleicht sogar Gefühle ausgetauscht
werden können auf alle Fälle Sensorik am
Körper sein wird erstmal werden solche
ki-tools zum Web Alltag mit diesem kann
jeder Kopf alles sprechen passend zum in
der Schweiz erfundenen World Wide Web
kann mit ein paar Eingaben auch der
Avatar unserer heute Moderatorin
Schweizerdeutsch so kann ich auch
Zuschauer in der Schweiz begrüße und
Umwelt weit alles gut die Wünsche und
jetzt zurück zu mir kurz
beim Fußball und Formel 1 genau mit dem
Motorsport fangen wir an Sergio Perez
hat das erste sprinterennen der Formel 1
in Aserbaidschan gewonnen der 33 Jahre
alte Mexikaner setzte sich in seinem Red
Bull Vorschau im Ferrari und Weltmeister
Max für das Tapen im zweiten Red Bull
durch der einzige deutsche Nico
Hülkenberg wurde 15
der Jubel der Siegers so kurz wie das
Rennen selbst Sergio Perez und sein
zweiter Saisonerfolg anders die Aussicht
des WM führende Max fürs Daten im Ziel
es sind die Folgen dieses Rennens von
Beginn an ist der Sprint in Baku eine
Harz über 17 Runden den Ferrari Pilot
Charles vor Perez und Verstappen der
gleich zu Beginn hier rechts im Bild vor
Mercedes Pilot George Russell in die
Bande gedrängt wird der Weltmeister von
an mit einem lidierten Fahrzeug
unterwegs und das entscheidende
Überholmanöver eingangsrunde acht
Personen erklärt und hält die Führung
bis ins Ziel mit Abstand folgt am Ende
von drei Max für Verstappen der
Holländer weiterführender in der
Gesamtwertung
Fußball an diesem Wochenende wieder das
fern Duell zwischen Bayern München und
Borussia Dortmund eine Strafraumszene
sorgte für heftige Reaktionen der
Dortmunder gestern beim Derby in Bochum
das 1:1 endete war gefolgt worden
Schiedsrichter Sascha Stegemann schaute
sich die Szene nicht noch mal an gab
keinen Elfmeter gestanden den Fehler
dann heute im ZDF Interview ein und
einem Tag Abstand und Nachmittag in der
Fernsehbilder muss man konzertieren dass
da ein Strafstoß für angebracht gewesen
wäre der das gestern Abend leider nicht
gegeben hat und deswegen die Situation
am Ende des Tages falsch gelöst wurde
alle Informationen zu Elfmeter
Diskussionen und zum 30 Spieltag ab 23
Uhr dann bei uns im Aktuellen
Sportstudio zu Gast isekiel Palacios
Argentiniens Weltmeister von Bayer
Leverkusen so und damit hat Bayern
morgen gegen den Tabellen letzten Hertha
BSC die Chance wieder Spitzenreiter zu
werden die bisherigen
samstags-ergebnisse wichtiger Sieg im
Abstiegskampf für Stuttgart 2:1 gegen
Gladbach Freiburg holt drei Punkte im
Kampf um die Champions League Plätze 1:0
in Köln Leipzig schlägt Hoffenheim 1:0
Union Berlin Leverkusen 0:0 Frankfurt
Augsburg
Schalke gegen Werder ausführlich im
Aktuellen Sportstudio und in der Tabelle
sehen wir Dortmund noch vorne Union
Berlin Punkt gleich jetzt mit Freiburg
auch Leipzig kommt dran die zweite
Tabellenhälfte beginnt mit Gladbach
Stuttgart verbessert sich auf 15 härter
tabellennetzter
die deutsche Eishockey
Nationalmannschaft hat die gute Form in
der Vorbereitung auf die WM im nächsten
Monat bestätigt die Mannschaft des neuen
Bundestrainers Harald Kreis gewann in
trentschienen gegen Gastgeber Slowakei
mit 4 zu 3 die Entscheidung fiel in der
Verlängerung durch den Treffer von
Kapitän Moritz Müller
aber noch gesehen das war's danke schön
für Morgen verspricht Christa Abend
trockenes Ausflugswetter Christian
Sievers freut sich auf Sie im heute
journal um Viertel vor elf wir sagen
Danke und wünschen Ihnen noch einen
richtig schönen Samstagabend bis morgen
wenn Sie mögen tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend es gibt einen neuen
europatemperaturrekord für April
vorgestern 38,8 Grad in corduga war
Südspanien üblich sind da im Moment um
25 Grad und das zeigt wieder wie sehr
sich unser Klima ändert auch heute gab
es dort noch um 35 Grad bei uns ist es
schon deutlich kühler das vor allem
heute Nacht im Norden kann es bis -1°
leisten Frost geben Bodenfrost ist
verbreitet in der norddeutschen tief
Ebene möglich am Oberrhein ist es mit 9
Grad milder und mild wird es morgen auch
im Westen und im Süden mit 16 bis 20
Grad die Temperaturen sind aber etwas
verhaltener in den höheren Lagen und im
Nordosten mit 11 bis 16 Grad dafür
scheint aber von den Küsten bis zum
Erzgebirge richtig viel die Sonne weil
abgesehen von ein bisschen Nebel morgens
und lockeren Wolkenfeldern an der Küste
Richtung Süden werden die Wolken dann
häufiger Schauer an den Alpen lassen
morgens überraschen nach und so wird das
ein rundum trockener Tag aber das ändert
sich am ersten Mai im Süden da gibt es
schauerartigen Regen der in die Mitte
ausgreift nachmittags vereinzelt auch
Gewitter und unter den Regenwolken nur
14 Grad im Nordosten gibt es aber bestes
Ausflugswetter bei 17 bis 20 Grad und in
den nächsten Tagen wird es bei ähnlichen
Temperaturen häufig trocken bleiben
tschüss